[Musique]
lagence martiniquaise de l'énergie n'est
plus officiellement depuis la semaine
dernière les mets avaient écrit en juin
2012 et avait pour mission première de
réfléchir à la transition énergétique en
martinique un enjeu majeur pour jour
allemand plaisir bonjour mes yeux le
temps bonjour mesdames et messieurs les
auditrices et auditeurs de martinique
produit vous êtes vous étiez jusqu'à la
semaine dernière président de cette
agence en tant que syndicat mixte
d'électricité la martinique dont vous
êtes les présidents le ce même qui est
membre fondateur de l'émeute ou comme
l'admr il ya la chance de
l'environnement de la maîtrise de
l'énergie ief y est aussi l'ex région
devenue 7e rachetons plaisir question
toute simple pourquoi là et me at-elle
été dissoute coûté 1 je crois qu'il faut
reprendre les choses dans leur contexte
quand même été créé on était au départ
vraiment ce moment là en train de mener
une réflexion sur les énergies nouvelles
et où depuis sas a beaucoup progressé
quand ça a été crié l'ademe a de son
côté mis en place l'observatoire l'oméga
qu'elle a financé la semelle ce même et
là c'était et la coller la région bien
entendu ont été les principaux
investisseurs au niveau de la
participation financière dans ce projet
qui ça a été suivi ensuite par des
partenaires comme et df la sara les 3
opci et le parc naturel régional de la
martinique
comme vous le constaterez il y a dans sa
quelque chose un petit peu c'était un
départ je pense que le
la région a voulu pousser que fait le
parc naturel régional martiniquais dans
l'énergie ce n'est pas tellement ça se
comprend pas tellement mais il fallait
bien mettre les choses en août
cette agence travaille à développer les
connaissances sur les matières
énergétiques développer un partenariat
avec des universités faire émerger des
solutions techniques pour notre
territoire dans le domaine de l'énergie
elle a fait un travail dans le
photovoltaïque c'est très noble et sur
très noble est reine mère est raide mais
pourquoi ça disparaît mais c'était une
volonté de faire des choses
à ce moment là aujourd'hui tout a évolué
et la structure telle qu'elle était ne
correspond plus vraiment à ce qu'on
voudrait continuer à ne pas avoir donné
tout simplement quelques tours de vis
quelques réglages et puis redémarrer sur
une nouvelle philosophie nouvelle ligne
éditoriale avec toujours cette agence
martiniquaise de l'énergie mais c'est ce
qui est fait vous avez alors qu'on va
même mais je suis navré doigt par le
taux de dissolution mais il fallait bien
dissoudre aujourd'hui pour les questions
qui sont des questions financières
nous avons c'est pas tout simplement une
décision politique écoutez vous avez
huit cent mille euros de budget et faire
fonctionner cette agence c'est trop
drôle c'est pas assez compte tenu que je
ne vais pas partir pas dire ses trousses
et pas assez
depuis que nous y sommes arrivés
monsieur bachand trésorier moi en tant
que président nous avons tout fait pour
réduire au maximum les coûts de
fonctionnement
bon mais il faut comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui et reste qu' à cette
agence il reste la collectivité la 7ème
et le semaine la ctm 300000 euros
le ce même 120000 euros budget
fonctionnement 800000 euros
vous ne croyez quand même pas que ont
fait fonctionner quelque chose sans
essence alors et excusez moi je vais
aller jusqu'au bout c'est la région la
raison principale est majeur de l'art
est aujourd'hui sachant que tout ça est
réfléchie étudiés il ya eu un bureau
d'études qui a été payé pour réfléchir à
l'évolution de cette ademe
et aujourd'hui nous avons pardon de 7 à
me2 7ème pareil de cette agence est
aujourd'hui nous avons un l'agencé
elle-même va perdurer à travers une
nouvelle structure qui va être mise en
oeuvre
l'institut territoriale de l'énergie
absolument et les locaux de sdf
bellefontaine vont être avons recevoir
cette agence entre autres pour l'instant
l' agence va dans des locaux qui
appartiennent aux semaines vous savez on
paie 6000 euros de loyer pour ou cinq ou
six personnes à lagence c'est quand même
très cher payé donc nous avons décidé on
a bien parlé à raisons budgétaires
en tout cas l'ancien président de la
structure âge mon plaisir l'ancien
président leur culture qui s'appelle
daniel chomet lui il a vu rouge karim
membre
il parle de gâchis de honte d'une preuve
de l'incompétence des élus de la
majorité tout en égrenant ce qui selon
lui est une réussite des gens fédérant
tout le monde les producteurs d'énergie
les collectivités c'est ce qu'il disait
dans un courrier qui a circulé ce
week-end
écoutez moi je ne vais pas relever tout
ça je vais vous dire quelque chose
l'ancien président a été à l'origine de
la création de cette agence et mais il
n'est plus en activité depuis quand même
un certain temps donc il ne sait pas
exactement dans le détail ce qui se
passe ce que le responsable de la
l'énergie à la ctm qui elle détient la
compétence la ctm le responsable qui est
monsieur boutrin a beaucoup travaillé
sur ce sujet et c'est lui qui a guidé
vers le pci pour que l' agence continue
et c'est lui qui nous a confirmé dans
une réunion de travail que j'ai eue avec
lui que le personnel de cette agence qui
est un personnel compétent sérieux
allait être protégés et c'est d'ailleurs
lui qui assure le fait que nous avons
aujourd'hui
l'outil qui est une pile qui se trouve
au françois qui est une pile qui doit
être suivi et le personnel la suit oui
on pourrait même dire que louis boutrin
a quand même répondu à daniel chow mais
il faut le préciser
une réponse de nouveaux traits qui n'a
pas tardé
le bilan énergie de l'ex gouvernement se
dit louis boutrelle bilan de l'ex
donnait le bilan d'énergie de l'ex
gouverneur régional est présenté comme
étant qu'à l'habitude et surtout il dit
loulou très toujours que les mène à rien
modifié l'inertie politique alors de la
transition énergétique
excusez moi mais je vais vous dire que
l' agence martiniquaise de l'énergie
n'avait pas vocation à s'occuper de ces
problèmes là je tiens ce que ce soit
clair donc si il y à un déficit dans ce
qui devait être fait lagence n'a pas à
voir cela ce n'était pas sa vocation
alors parlons de ceux de cette nouvelle
structure qui verra très bientôt le jour
l'institut territoriale de l'énergie qui
va qui va quand même travaillé à
fonction de ce plan plus cette
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
c'est ça l'important il faut regarder
devant soi
la transition énergétique en martinique
tout le monde est concerné tout le monde
envie de faire que ça avance écoutez je
vais vous dire oui tout le monde a envie
il se trouve que travaille ensemble
la collectivité territoriale
martiniquaise et df le ce même l'état à
travers la des mails à des halles c'est
ainsi qu'a été créé le ptm qui permet de
programmer cette énergie nouvelle grille
des programmes territoriale de maîtrise
de l'énergie
et c'est ensemble déjà des résultats
mais bien sûr nous avons diminué
énormément énormément de façon très
sensible les les
giga watts qui sont utilisés sur le
territoire c'était vous savez vous me
connaissez je vais pas vous donner un
chiffre
parce que je ne veux pas vous donner un
chiffre si je ne suis pas précis mais je
sais dans ma tête lors de grandir je
vais pas dire là mais si vous voulez
questionner on peut vous l'envoyez plus
tard mais c'est énorme
on a fait un gros travail et les deux
dernières années ont vu diminuer la
consommation parce que les martinelli
conscient les objectifs c'est quoi elles
font plaisir c'est atteint d'une sorte
d'auto suffisance énergétique c'est la
volonté parce que nous y sommes
contraints par des textes qui régissent
la csl l'énergie et notamment dans nos
dom et on est censé pouvoir athènes
cette autonomie dans une période qui est
relativement courte et 2030
vous avez on espère tous que tout ce
qu'on ira le plus loin que recèle la
querelle qui existe en politique ne
reste qu ils ne risquent pas de chaque
fois de ben ali ses volontés à droite à
gauche
alors là comme une pression sociale il
s'agit de viol temps si vous me
permettez
là je vais prendre deux minutes pour
vous dire quelque chose
chacun est comme il est - je n'aime pas
les combats surtout les combats inutiles
j'aime qu'on travaille en consensus vous
avez vous venez de me dire que monsieur
chaumet a fait ses réflexions c'est son
droit d'être a répondu b et que l'autre
a répondu c'est également son doigt moi
je vais vous dire je me rends métropole
dans des ministères et autres
et qu'est ce que j'entends j'entends que
que ce soit la réunion la guadeloupe la
guyane mayotte
quand ils viennent ils partent tous ils
parlent tous ensemble même langage nos
politiques
on me dit quand vous martiniquais vous
venez vous parler et puis après le
départ il y en a qui téléphonent
beaulieu surtout faut pas écouter ce que
je suis là à dire parce que je suis là
donc la faute si ça mais pardon la fota
qui se cherche un nouvel esprit des
politiques d'ici mai abel j'espère
qu'ils vont comprendre qu'on ne méritons
pas de pointer du doigt et je ne pointe
personne du doigt - je dis simplement
que nous
vont comprendre que si nous nous mettons
pas ensemble pour pouvoir écouter vous
savez moi je pense que le plus simple
c'est de regarder ce qui se passe dans
une famille
vous pouvez avoir remarqué une femme qui
sont pas d'accord sur quelque chose mais
quand ils vont s'exprimer
il s'exprime ensemble même si après ils
disent tiens tu as dit ça on a dit si
c'était pas bon je suis pas d'accord
mais 2,20 les gens ils sont ensemble
c'est l'union qui fait la force et pas
la désunion comment sommes nous arrivés
où nous en sommes parmi les différents
territoires d'outre-mer notre autre
niveau
il est ce qu'il est parce qu'on se passe
son temps à se battre je suis fatigué de
dire on passe son temps à discuter sur
quel sera le statut de la martinique est
ce qu'on va vers l'indépendance
est-ce qu'on va verser est-ce qu'on va
vers ça les autres écoutez et regardez
bien ce qui se passe chez les autres
vous n'entendez pas ça il travaille
entre eux et ça c'est notre gros
problème monsieur est temps que nous
serons dans dans cette situation nous
n'avancerons pas alors là aujourd'hui on
travaille sur le pci et bien oui il faut
que monsieur chaud mais accepte de
comprendre qu'il y a un travail qui est
en train d'être fait ce n'est peut-être
pas parfait mais il ya une volonté elle
est là et on y arrivera monsieur merci
ralph mon plaisir d'avoir été avec nous
rappelle que vous êtes toujours le
président de cette agence martiniquaise
de l'énergie qui est en cours de
dissolution immédiate à l'aune institut
territoriale de l'énergie et j'assume
mes responsabilités
bonne journée à vous merci monsieur
violent merci mesdames et messieurs
[Musique]